if you want to know how to take control
cast out the lies and focus on what
matters then this video is for you
I always start thinking about what I
needed to do and the more that I thought
about what I needed to do the more
anxiety i felt the more self down would
rise and i'm get trapped upstairs you
have to realize you have to know you
have to accept that all your excuses are
lies so your business failed you sucked
you couldn't figure it out pick yourself
up get a job become practical go back at
it in three years if that's what you are
what's that believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
i believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that i want to see explode
out into the world now I started the
best entrepreneur videos of the month
series to try to highlight some of the
great videos that are happening in the
world of entrepreneurship these are some
of my friends who putting out amazing
content that maybe you've never heard of
them before or maybe you didn't have
time to check out their channel and
consume everything so I put together
what I love from their channels I wanted
to share with you their best highlights
from December 2017 joy
so I need y'all do me a favor for real
listen to me very closely I'm gonna show
you how to be successful you have to
understand that your losses and that's
why I want you to look at them every day
because your losses fuel you in a way
the way that you're winning can never
feel you well you take an L you take it
you take the right L you like I'm gonna
be very cautious on that next move I
make if you're smart so number one every
single day I want you to go to bed at
night stop playing games and be honest
about the wins and the losses so I
always remember where I came from I
remember all the errands I took because
when you forget the ails that's when you
like you big and bad I remember those
are the ones man those are the ones that
humble me those are the ones that when I
get on stage and is 10,000 people and I
think about what I did to my mom and my
father who raised me I think about the
hard disappointed myself I think about
disappointing my wife I think about
disappointing my kids like I had a story
with my daughter where you know I'm
saying I discipline my daughter about
three years ago and I don't know that I
wish I could get it back but I wish I
could get the experience back cuz it
because it was one of those things where
for years so you could tell she was like
yo I can't believe you I was just like
man guy was a loss for me and it took us
a while to repair our relationship I
took applause so when I think about
those losses and humbles me and I can't
be like floating with the smoke at the
event he upset smoke at the event the
music is playing and they do miss coming
from lunch in Michigan motivational
speaker in the world I don't run out
like I run out like and I hope me and my
daughter could get out
peddle killers hope she'll take that
detail relationship with her husband and
me and my son man I should've okay you
let yourself off like one of those days
I went on stage with the losses I'm
trying to help somebody out you wonder
why you can't get to the next level
you're not helpful enough to get to the
next level you focus on your win and not
your losses I need you to switch that
all right let's go to the next one yup
LeBron won
LeBron is lost and guess what as a
result of that when he win you feel why
this is the time he came out they told
him through the king they called the
bride the king before you ever wanted
they told me with the king he was
getting shoe contract he was the man but
he never won a championship but when he
got that first one he was in tears why
because all the losses he had up to that
was just like it was a relief you saw
Jordan joy cried that year when he won
the championship but he lost his loss
today that is the epitome of wins and
losses you win the championship one year
set records and you lose your dad and
the same that's the day and that lets
let me tell you something listen to me
young people along this journey of
winning expect to take some blows and
when you expect to take some blows it's
not gonna hurt as much it's not the
thing that happened to you that broke
you it was the fact that you didn't
prepare for losses and guess what they
come in the losses are coming I don't
care how successful your marriage is how
good you are as a parent what you do
financially like if you do not pencil in
losses when they happen I'm telling you
they gonna break you I leave you with
this it only takes a couple more wins to
turn that whole situation around it only
took a couple classes
it only took a GED to a race that was a
high school dropout it didn't take a PhD
it didn't take a master's degree
took a GED to turn everything around it
took a four-year degree to give me here
at Michigan State you got to get back
off the game and erase those losses into
a couple win there's nothing like a
couple wins that makes me feel good
about you
okay I've started to power five second
decisions I realize because I was really
stuck that I was stuck thinking about
what I needed to do and the more that I
thought about what I needed to do the
more anxiety I felt the more self down
would rise and I would get trapped
upstairs and I realized that within five
seconds flat fear anxiety south doubt
procrastination was taking over and
making decisions for me and when I saw
that five-second window I realized holy
cow if I were to move within five
seconds I could be procrastination I
could beat self that I could beat the
things upstairs in my head that were
stopping me and I could take control in
those same five seconds and that insight
that your life comes down to five second
decisions that you can change anything
in five seconds flat because you can
change how you think you can change what
you're doing that insight has changed
everything about my life because it gave
me the insight that I needed and a tool
that goes along with that five seconds
window to make change
the chronic excuse maker how do you stop
making excuses
this is actually pretty simple and I
said it the other day and you have to
realize you have to know you have to
accept that all your excuses are lies
their lies all of them think about the
things that you tell yourself the lies
you used to rationalize taking the easy
road taking the easy road and leaving
discipline behind think about them you
don't have time that's a lie you don't
have support that's a lie
you don't have the equipment or the gear
lies you don't you don't know the best
way who cares that's a lie or you're too
old or you're too young of course you're
too old or too young lie and there's
you're too busy sure you are that's high
and you're too tired or you're too sore
or you're just plain not feeling it lies
lies lies and the list goes on and on
and on then it doesn't stop if you don't
make it stop so recognize recognize the
excuses are not valid
they aren't they're trumped up they're
conjured up they're fabricated their
lies
and how do you stop the lies you stop
the lies with the truth the truth the
truth will set you free the truth will
stand and the truth will deliver you
from procrastination and laziness and
the downward spiral that comes with a
lack of discipline so don't believe the
lies believe the truth and the truth is
you have time you have the skill you
have the knowledge and the support and
the willpower and the discipline to get
it done
so cast out the lies burn them down and
listen to the truth and live the truth
and go out and get it done
anytime something sucks like remember it
doesn't matter in the macro there are
only so few things that you will think
about on your deathbed there are only so
few things that will matter to you as
you continue to glide and guide through
your life so understand whatever you're
upset about right now fundamentally
doesn't matter
it just doesn't so he broke up with you
teasing doozy so your boss told you suck
they suck
so your business failed you sucked you
couldn't figure it out pick yourself up
get a job become practical and go back
out of in three years if that's what you
are it all doesn't matter
in the end what matters is did you do it
your way did you die on your sword did
you do it on your feet
did you listen to yourself and did you
do it the right way
you started with the magazine the
magazine allowed you to sell music music
transfer translated into a record out a
record label use the financing as I
understand from the record label sale
record label for the airline and etc etc
is that a is that what you prescribed
because everyone wants to not everyone
but the people that are at least
listening and watching to the show here
like they want to find their thing and
that is a question that I hear so often
in entrepreneurial circles is how do I
know what to focus on what advice would
you give someone who's wondering like
how do I find my passion and how do I
pull on these threads and and where they
going to lead to help us understand how
you got started and how they should
think about it well I think I mean most
most people listening to this show know
know what their passion is and and then
it could be a hobby it could be you know
they could love reading they could love
playing tennis they couldn't you they'll
have passions and if you have a passion
it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life involved in that passion and quite
often you can turn your passion into a
business you can see that maybe there's
some aspect of your passion that people
are not doing that well and and you know
you can save screw it you know I I could
do it better and I think all you know if
you spend your life with your eyes open
looking for looking for things that
frustrate youth looking for a gap gaps
in the market that's all the business is
is that it's fulfilling that you know
filling in a gap and doing it better
than it's been done by anybody else and
and and you know it people who don't
have closed minds will most likely find
find that or to find those opportunities
now I suspect there will be a hundred
people who will have come up with that
idea before you but those 100 people you
know
won't have had the courage just to go
and do something about it so you know so
there's a few people who just say right
you know that I'm going to give it a go
that and often end up you know being
being successful
do you feel fear when you have I speak
sometimes yeah before a little bit
before like I used to be terrified going
onstage mm-hmm but then I really
practiced over and over - over
Toastmasters Oh smash I know she listens
I her I listened to the five postmasters
I think we should call it the pod the
pod I'm really into calling it the pod I
keep trying to make it happen you're
like you're not so fast
yeah pod Toastmaster is like saved my
life because I knew that I wanted to be
able to share my message but I was too
scared to get in front of five people
yeah and I was like okay I need to
overcome this and you just got to
practice your fear yes yes 100% hundred
percent I believe that I do I walk
myself through moments like the I you
know visualize every single moment of a
show or performance and I walk myself
through the entire thing and I like
visualize that all going perfectly and
me feeling peaceful throughout it and
powerful mmm
it's so so important to get
crystal-clear on the things that you
think are important you need to write
this down when you're 90 or you're a
hundred years old and you are looking
back at your life and all the amazing
things that you did what do you want to
see when especially you're looking back
at this time period in your life what
would you like to say would you like to
say that that was a time period in my
life where I conformed while I followed
what everybody said I took the safe path
and just kind of played it safe or do
you want to look back and say no that
was the time period where I struck out
and followed my dreams and whether or
not it went perfectly
I found out if that was something that I
was capable of doing I learned a ton now
I hope and I think that you're probably
with me and that it's the second one but
when you do this a lot of things will
become clear to you and I actually did
this many years ago and I was working a
normal job as a consultant and it was
very clear to me that I did not want to
just work until I was 65 what I wanted
to do was to move to Brazil with a bunch
of my friends to try to start this
online business thing to see if it could
work and when I wrote it down my day the
way that I wanted to go waking up in the
morning knocking on my friend's door we
lived in the same apartment we'd go out
to the beach together we'd take a stroll
we'd be drinking caipirinhas I wrote the
whole thing out when I got clear on that
it was so motivating that when everybody
when anybody would come up to me and say
Charlie you're crazy you're gonna quit
your job you're gonna try to start this
online business
it didn't faze me because I didn't value
the security of the job in the same way
that I valued pursuing the stream
because I've gotten clear on it so take
this time this is so so critical not
just for this topic for everything in
your life write down your values it's so
helpful
clarity comes from confusion Nietzsche
said it so well he said chaos gives
birth to dancing stars so whether you're
an entrepreneur scaling your business
please understand you will reach a
plateau if your growth and if you push
to the next level the way you get there
through the process of messiness and
confusion there's nothing wrong
everything is right
confusion means you're growing if you
are an athlete and you're at a certain
plateau of your sport your acumen your
game please understand that things now
must break down to break through you
let's say you're a marathoner or a boxer
or a yogi or a swimmer you're gonna
reach a certain level through your
practice and your study and your
devotion and your commitment and then if
you want to get to the next level of
world class you're gonna have to break
down things your your core beliefs your
muscles your emotional architecture even
on the physical side your muscles need
to break down it's called micro tearing
and the muscle will break down then you
rest it and then when you recover guess
what happens your muscle is stronger
that is growth in your personal
relationships you're gonna get to a
certain plateau and then what's going to
happen if you want to get to your next
level of understanding and commitment
and love you're gonna have to tear
things down that is not wrong that is
the process of rising to legendary and
so the a players and the legendary
leaders understand that in business in
your physical life in your relationship
life in your spiritual life in your
financial life breakdown is necessary
for breakthroughs a lot of the
Philosopher's say the very nature of
growth means you will endure a lifetime
series of cycles lifetime of death and
rebirth
your family's important your dreams are
important these are the things that need
to be first on your mind every day not
last it's even the first or it's last my
dreams are first every day then my wife
then my kids I could take care of my
wife and my kids now would you agree I
abandoned this this is the fuel for Who
I am I abandon this dream and then I end
up I can't take care of them and then
I'm gonna tell them what it's alright
that you didn't win no it's not alright
if you don't win you need to win how
many of you need to win more okay if you
don't control your environment folks
somebody else is going to control your
environment you guys have run teams and
run organizations if you do not control
your environment someone else will
control your environment you are being
controlled in your environment right now
CNBC CNN MSNBC the parents the kids the
Twitter the Facebook the YouTube the
Google the snapchats are your
environment your friends and your
relatives your uncle's your aunts the
garbage dump called planet Earth that
you live on is mostly broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with me when I was 45 years old
I'm like I'm gonna control my
environment I'm gonna take every penny I
have all the energy I have all the
resources I have and I'm gonna improve
me if I got to go broke in the process
because I'm already broke look if you're
not fulfilled - you're if you're not
reaching your full potential every day
you're broke right now
if you're doing something big you're
gonna get haters if you're doing
something that nobody has done before
that is game-changing that is breaking
the status quo you're gonna have people
who want to hold on to the past who want
to hold on to their way of thinking they
don't want to see other people become
successful and so they're gonna hate on
you the more you're off being bold and
trying to do something different
creative new could be on it on a global
level or coop just be doing something
that's not normal in your family right
then you're gonna have haters you're
gonna have the people who are against it
because they stand for the status quo
the more you stand for something big you
understand that you stand against
something else so the people who like
that stuff even if it's a negative way
of life they're gonna fight for it and
they're gonna see you as the enemy and
attack you what's the alternative the
alternative is to live such a small life
to never take any risks to only do what
everybody else tells you to do never
have a life of your own
so that you don't risk offending
everybody that's a pretty crappy life
and it's not that you're out there
intentionally trying to hurt people it's
not saying look at me and how great I am
and you suck right it's not it's not
putting that kind of vibe out but just
by you being you and trying to do
something big and bold it's gonna upset
people not because they actually hate
you it's because they hate something
within themselves I look at my message
and believe it's powerful it's positive
it's uplifting how do you hate on
believe how do you hate on somebody
who's encouraging people to untap their
potential right but people do I think it
takes some getting used to and I think
that the the more you are out there the
more content you're creating the bigger
your company grows and the bigger that
you get and the more of an audience that
you build up of customers or people
following you then the more you're gonna
be seen as a target for a certain select
group of people and I used to in the
early days of me have my youtube channel
I used to take it personally I used to
be really upset when somebody left a
negative comment I used to you know only
see that one negative comment and ignore
the 99 positive ones I used to try to
fight with that person and explain
myself or try to change them and try to
bring them around and in that process
sometimes at work sometimes
to explain my perspective and bring them
around to my point of view or at least
get some kind of common ground and
sometimes it didn't sometimes I couldn't
change them the thing is it just takes
so much time and effort like is it worth
spending all that time on that one
person you're trying to make a positive
impact with an easy shift in a little
bit versus investing that time into the
99 other people who love you who care
about you who we're really consuming
that you can go a lot further with and
it sounds crass and it sounds it sounds
really terrible to say don't spend time
on those people ignore them but the fact
is they steal so much of your energy and
it's always an opportunity cost like
that time spent if I can help 20 people
achieve amazing results or try to help
one person achieve subpar results that's
just a little bit better than what they
were getting before what's the best use
of my time and so that was one thing
that really helped me shift away from
trying to fight with them and try to
change them and just leave them leave
them there leave those comments up but
it still hurt right like it still hurt
like god stings that comment the thing
that really shifted it forward for me of
not caring of putting things in
perspective was me trying to put myself
in their shoes imagine somebody who's
who's gets off by going to a YouTube
channel or going to a customer site or
going to an e-commerce site or whatever
it is and leaving a negative comment
we were like a hateful negative comment
no I'm not a constructive criticism nada
Evan you know your hoodie is off today
you know get the lint roller or
something right like constructive
criticism just just nasty hate stuff
what would motivate somebody to do that
like imagine that that this is how they
get up this is how they are happy like
how crappy a life do you have to have
that this is the thing that makes you
come alive and feel happy and just by
shifting that perspective now when I see
negative comment like that it honestly
just makes me feel sorry for that person
that this is the only way to get
attention this is this is the best part
of their days the highlight is be able
to come in leave hate comments their
entire life must really suck and
that shift allows me not to care because
it's easy to say well don't care don't
pay attention of the haters and it
doesn't mean you have to engage with
them but it can still hurt that comment
now I try to look at well who is this
person sleeping he tambien if I'm
feeling sorry for them it's hard to it's
hard to still feel the sting when you
feel sorry for somebody at this summer
that you feel sorry for it says
something negative at least for me it's
hard for me to actually digest it to
feel like it's anywhere remotely true
because I look at their life and say
this person has a really crappy life and
I don't want anything to do with them
you know I don't want to be around them
if they're gonna be spewing that kind of
hate and so I found that that really
helps and so for those of you who might
be afraid of doing something big because
you're afraid of haters you're afraid of
negativity you're afraid of controversy
you're afraid of ruffling a few feathers
understand that you serve nobody by
playing small and you can't let a vocal
few minority people prevent you from
going off and doing something great and
when you see do see those negative
reviews you do see that that personal
hatred or criticism just try to put
yourself in their shoes ask yourself
what kind of life is this person have
but this is this is their highlight that
come and criticize me and if you feel
sorry for them at least for me it takes
the sting out of the comment so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple so it would be like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details